red blue green orange lightsabers come
in Many Colors some rarer than others
but what do the orange Sabers in Ahsoka
actually mean lightsaber colors have
grown in complexity as the Star Wars
Canon evolved in the original trilogy it
was pretty much accepted that blue and
green lightsabers were used by the noble
Jedi while red lightsabers were
preferred by the evil Sith more colors
have been added over the years however
to lend greater mythology around the use
of this iconic weapon and now Ahsoka
will introduce many viewers to the
orange lightsaber elegant weapon
but I'm all civilized day the Ahsoka
trailer has already shown balin's skull
and shinhati wielding orange lightsabers
these characters act as minor
antagonists in the series so their usage
of orange lightsabers makes a lot of
sense this is not quite the blood red
shading used by Sid but it does signify
how balen and shin operate within a gray
area of the forest Balin is a former
Jedi who survived Order 66 and became a
mercenary with Shin acting as his
Apprentice both of them likely have
experience navigating between the dark
and light sides of the force which is
why their lightsabers don't entirely
fall into either camp but while the
orange lightsaber makes its live-action
debut in Ahsoka it already boasts a rich
history in Star Wars lore even if it
hasn't always been canonical Gamers
might have first-hand experience using
orange lightsabers if they played Jedi
fall in order the orange lightsaber was
a pre-order bonus offered by respawn
entertainment which means protagonist
calcus is technically counted among the
Jedi who have held one before however
seeing how this is mostly an aesthetic
Choice as opposed to a reflection of
cow's character it's hard to count him
as the first canonical orange lightsaber
user to find others one must look toward
the Legend's side of Star Wars this is
the expanded universe that sprung forth
after George Lucas's first six Star Wars
movies which served to explore the
history of the Galaxy even further the
pre-disney EU has since been deemed
non-canonical but it could offer hints
into the true nature of balance skull
and shinhati within Legends orange
lightsabers are most often used by gray
Jedi they are not fully members of the
Jedi Order utilizing both the light and
dark sides of the force we are no Jedi
in these instances orange lightsabers
represent their middle ground with
orange being a cross between red
lightsabers used by The Sith and yellow
Sabers used by guards of the Jedi Temple
it's also worth noting that the video
game nights of the Old Republic 2
suggests that Darth Revan may have used
an orange lightsaber after his
Redemption and that's a character with
more than a little experience walking
the line between light and dark that
said several full-fledged members of the
Jedi Order used orange lightsabers too
for instance yaddle wielded an orange
blade in Legends before it was replaced
with a standard green blade for Tales of
the Jedi additionally placoon used an
orange lightsaber in Legends although
he's been depicted using different
colors in various other media it's fair
to assume that for more casual viewers
Ahsoka represents a proper introduction
of orange lightsabers into Star Wars
Canon opening the doors for exciting new
possibilities
sadly it's not entirely clear whether
someone will actually use the words gray
Jedi in any capacity in Ahsoka while
some aspects of the legend stories have
become Canon such as the use of force
projection it's ultimately up to the
folks at lucasfilm to decide which
elements to incorporate in terms of
orange lightsabers entering the
live-action fold this could either be
something familiar to those who know
about the extended universe or something
new entirely no matter what happens
balance skull and shinhati look like
powerful foes for Ahsoka Tano in her
comrades to contend with what these
orange lightsabers mean for the future
of the Star Wars Canon however remains
to be seen
foreign